so um
i'm eurozone embosser i'm one of the
pandas core developer
and i'm also involved with some of the
geospatial packages in in python
and at the moment i'm uh working at the
voltron data we're a company that is
building upon the apache arrow project
um and so at vote on data i'm
able to yeah maintain the the python
pi arrow bindings to apache arrow
if you're interested in that i'm still
here the full day but so this talk is
not about apachero but about pandas
and i'm going to focus on the the copy
and view part of this title um or
yeah
how we can get rid of the setting with
copy warning um so when it comes to
copies and views when how people
the easiest way to run into
something related to that um is with
this warning the setting with copy
warning a value is trying to be set on a
slice
on the copy of a slice from a data frame
complicated
sentence um but maybe quick
show offense so who has already used
pandas in the room and you can keep your
hand up if you already um
if you encountered the warning
okay so many people and maybe you have
been annoyed by it or
wondered what it is or
run away in
in terror but in any case it's it's uh
it's a topic that
gets quite some attention or
confuses people there are lots of if you
do a google search there are lots of
blog posts blog posts that and very
lengthy posts that try to explain
um what it is where it comes from what
you can do
we need to to get rid of it or to fix
your pandas codes
um
just a few screenshots from from a greek
google search
um
now
the actual um so what's the the the
fundamental copy and view concept
um so
when it comes to
you have a certain data frame and you
derive a second data frame from it
either
um for example with an indexing
operation uh so it's shown here so you
have a second data frame
and the second data frame
can either be a view which means that
the data of the
df2 in this case
is actually still
sharing the data with the original data
frame
or it can be completely new data so it's
the data is copied um
why is this important um or
when does it matter is that um
because those views in numpy are mutable
is that if you would mutate
a value in this df2
because the data is shared also the
original data frame is updated or in
case of the the copy
only the the second data frame is
updated um
so that's the fundamental
yeah aspect of copy versus a view
in this case
so
for a few examples to illustrate the
problem
so
yeah small toy example i create a data
frame df
um
i create a second data frame which is a
subset of the original data frame in
this case by filtering the rows with the
with the condition with boolean mask
and then i'm
mutating i'm changing the the second
data frame subset
in this case setting a specific row and
column value
this trick is the warning and
so the question with regarding this copy
and view
is then
by changing the subsets the second data
frame did also the original data frame
change
i don't know if people who thinks that
it will have changed
you can raise your hand a few people
um and who thinks that it didn't change
the original data frame
a little bit more people and many people
didn't raise their hand probably because
you don't know and that's perfectly fine
that also illustrates my points
so in this case it didn't
update the original data frame but if i
slightly change the example so the code
is the same only the how i create the
subsets
i'm still selecting rows but not anymore
using a mask with a boolean committed
condition
but with a slice so in this case
it actually does change the original one
another example
now i'm selecting columns selecting
multiple columns
same question does the original data
frame change
in this case no it does not
another example i'm selecting a single
column um in this case you actually
don't get the warning
and it also updates the
the original data frame um
but so
few examples to illustrate this and i
think what
um a problem with this is that it's
quite confusing it's difficult to
understand
or to predict which of the two will
happen you get this warning that
confuses people
and
and to be sure i only took like a few
simple examples i could have made it
harder with more corner cases um
so even for expert users of pandas it's
often difficult to predict what is
actually happening
it means that you need to be aware of
this concept of copy versus you you need
to know the rules in numpy because for
example the the example of
the boolean masking why does it not
update here is because in numpy a mask
fancy indexing always creates a copy
while a slice
can create a view
and
but
you need to so you need to be aware of
that and also how it translates to
pandas because we don't exactly follow
numpy
you also get a lot of
copying as i will directly show
getting back to the original setting
with copy warning
the reason that it's um that pandas
introduced it so in the previous
examples i created explicitly a second
data frame as a subset
um
but where the original like the original
use case for the warning is when you do
what is called chained assignments where
you do
multiple indexing operations uh after
each other with the final set item with
the final assignment so and a small
example here so the the this line
actually works here's the goal is to
update the original data frame the one
line works the other notes because there
is a different order in
which um
here we are first selecting the column
and then selecting the rows in the
second case is the other way around
and that's the reason that we are in the
second case
raising the warning that
you might want to try you're trying to
update the data frame but it didn't
actually work
now if you rewrite this the the the the
second example that doesn't work um in
two lines
so first we are selecting our rows
that gets that becomes a temporary
variable
um and then on this temporary variable
we then
assign
the value to that specific column so
basically for python this is very
equivalent those the last line here or
this
but here you see you are getting very
close to the example that i used
originally where i create a subset and
then
want to
work further with this subset
um
and that's not the reason that in this
last example you also get this warning
although maybe in that case you actually
don't care about the original data frame
so that's a typical thing that people
say how to solve this or the blog post
in documentation so either you actually
wanted to update your actual data frame
so
this is the line that didn't work so the
warning also says you can use dot lock
to do it in one go so pause the both the
row and column selection directly inside
the dot log
or an alternative is you can use assign
to update a certain column
and then with those methods
you also don't run in the into the
running
in many cases you're actually creating a
subset of a filtering your data frame
and you don't care about
that the original data frame might or
might not be updated you just want to
work further with your subset
and in that case if you want to get rid
of the burning you could do a filter
warning and and just hide all the
warnings um but the typical thing that
people do is add a copy
and then you also don't get a warning if
you then mutate this subset but in this
case as i just mentioned with the
boolean mask you actually already
the data in this subset is already a
copy of the original data frame so
you're doing an additional unnecessary
copy
and that's so comes back to my third
point here that yeah this is one example
of where
pandas will create
lots of copies
unnecessary often
another example where this happens is in
meta chaining so i use a tweet from matt
harrison he's
has written books about pandas and
teaches a lot and
he's a fan of of meta chaining he makes
it very long you can be i mean in favor
of that or not
but it's something certainly a valid way
to write panda's code with meta chain
after each other and it's something that
many people do so i simplified based on
on this example from him i simplified it
a little bit to this example where
i think you rather typical
cleaning
initial cleaning workflow of your data
frame so some from somewhere you have a
data frame you're renaming some columns
replacing dots with underscores to make
its uh
python
names
updating a certain column
changing the
type of some column dropping some
columns dropping some rows based on
for missing values
and resetting the index and so
quite
i mean
straightforward steps each of them
but the question here um what is on on
the on the slide is which of those steps
is actually copying the data frame and
so
that are all the steps that are scoping
the data frame while
it's actually not needed because it's
directly used in the net next step and
yeah we are copying and copying and
copying the data
without good reason
and the reason that we copy is methods
return on new objects and that new
object should not if you change it
update the original so that's the reason
that we currently every time do a copy
tool
but
when you rename columns you get a new
data frame with new column names but it
could perfectly share the data with the
original one if you don't further
mutate the actual data the same for
assign of course and as type
of course the columns that you're
changing there the data changes but all
the other columns that you're not
changing with assign or as type are also
copied while it's not inserted the same
for drop the columns that you don't drop
we copy
reset index we only change the index but
we also copy all the other data so
that's um
yeah
in a case where a lot of copies happen
in in pandas there is an in place
keyword that avoids sometimes the copy
but not always it's also a very unclear
aspect of pandas and we typically also
don't recommend to use it
might also get deprecated um that's
another uh thing so
can we do better i'm personally
convinced that we actually can make this
easier and and
and also more performance and and
improved pandas in in that way and so
the proposal that
has been uh discussed already um for
some time
um
is based on this
single rule
any data frame or series derived from
another
either with an indexing operation or or
method call
always behaves as a
so a single rule that we can apply on
all those examples that we have seen um
implication of this is or put it in a
different way is that if you actually
want to mutate the data frame um it's
only the object itself that will change
and not any other objects that might
be derived or might be the parent data
frame so
the proposal is not to change the fact
that data frames are mutable that would
be a
but if you mutate
a data frame
it will only be that data frame that
gets changed and not any other
data frame so
i think this is simpler
yeah
we will be simpler to understand a more
consistent user experience we can get
rid of the setting with copyrighting we
can avoid a lot of uh copies i will go
into those uh points i'm getting back to
our examples
so again the same question
changing the subset
data frame does it also change the
apparent data frame so if you apply this
proposed rule then the answer is no
because subset is a different object and
mutating subset will not
change
another object df
and then
for all those examples we can give the
same answer no it's a different object
so it will not change the original data
frame same here and same for the
last case as well
so i think
personally this will yeah give
a more
consistent and easier to understand a
user experience i'm personally also
convinced that it's
much closer to what people expect what
expectations are
especially in in cases like um
like this i don't think that many people
expect or want that if you change this
filter data frame that it also updates
the original one um
yeah um
and
a second argument or second advantage is
that we can get rid of the uh the
warning itself
um because it's now clear there is no
com possible confusion so if you look at
the or the example that i used so the
with current pandas the one way works
the other way doesn't work um with the
proposal both wouldn't work because if
you look at the case that did work right
now and rewrite it again in this two
line
with a temporary variable we are first
getting a column this is a new object
and then we are
mutating this new object so the rule
says
you only change the object itself and
not the other object
and so that means that this changed
assignment will basically never work and
so we also don't need to warn in all
cases where you might or might not be
trying to do change assignments
of course this case currently works so
there will need to be a transition
period where we also start to run for
that case as we do for the other case um
and ideally maybe to try to smooth the
transition it would also be nice if you
can uh maybe raise an error for that in
the future uh if it never works we can
actually try to raise an error for it um
the other case where you get a setting
with copyrighting is that you don't
you're not actually trying to mutate the
original one so that was the case where
one of the solution is to add a copy
that's very simple we no longer need to
add this copy to get rid of the warning
and you don't need the additional
unnecessary copy in this case
um
so
the um
that already comes back to the so the
third advantage that i mentioned here
about
no longer need
this this defensive copy
um
but so that's something i want to go a
little bit um
into detail and i um highlighted one
part of the
the the single uh rule is that um
a new data frame will behave
as a copy and so it doesn't say that it
is a copy
only that it behaves as a copy and so
that's
um
something so we um
that makes that we can actually delay
this copy and maybe even never
actually do the copy if it's not needed
and so
we are we are using the copy on right
term to explain this
the term is also used in other contexts
but i think it um it's it's fitting here
as well and so the guarantee is that
the new object
behaves as a copy so for the user it
looks as a copy but internally in pandas
we can still use a view when possible to
avoid making a copy but make the fact
that it's a view make it an
implementation detail instead of
something that the user needs to
understand when or when it doesn't
happen
to illustrate is a bit more so
assume that you have a data frame
here
and you have a data frame so you create
the subsets
i used here the example of
selecting multiple columns
selecting a subset of your columns
and so currently
i think so this is a case where it's not
a view currently in pandas
but we could perfectly make this subset
a view of the original data frame so
that the data in those columns of the
subset that's actually shared
that is still the the same data as from
the original data frame so that we don't
make the copy up front
if you then
modify this subset
at that moment
we can
so for example here i'm mutating now i'm
updating the values in this first column
of the subset
and at that moment to ensure that
the the guarantee that we give that it
behaves as a copy um and which means
that if you update the subset it
wouldn't update the original one at that
moment we can
um
yeah
cut the ties between those two data
frames for this column and actually copy
the data of the original column um
and then we can mutate this copy to
ensure
it to the guarantee that we give that it
behaves as a copy
the advantage of this is that
we can avoid copies initially
and
and in many cases you will actually
never mutate the results so you maybe
never need to do this copy
a disadvantage is that you you you get a
copy later on or you can get a copy
later on maybe at an unexpected moment
when you're actually
mutating data
the same applies for so
the copy and write i showed
on the previous slide is for indexing
but we can use the same mechanism if we
implement it in pandas for all the
method shading so all those steps that
we're making a copy
we can actually
use the same mechanism and
we we don't need to copy
the data in every step
only when you would actually try to
modify one of the resulting data frames
at that moment we can make the copy
but in this method chaining
we are constantly returning a new data
frame so in all those steps we are never
mutating the the actual data
of the at least for many columns we are
here with assigning as type you are
changing data for certain columns but
all the other columns um they never need
to be copied in all those different
steps it's actually only the the the one
uh lining this this yeah uh workflow is
dropping a that's actually creating a
copy but that's because it's
dropping rows and for that operation you
yeah inherently need to copy the data to
to a new um to new arrays to get
contiguous data when when you drop some
uh rows
um but all the others could in principle
use this delayed copy uh mechanism
to avoid a lot of copies
so
that gets me to
the end of this presentation
i'm personally convinced that yeah that
this would be a a nice improvement to
pandas there are of course not only
advantages but um yeah that are the the
i think for me the main um advantages
that we can get out of this um it will
also um i think make pandas
um
more consistent with for example other
data frame libraries on monday there was
a
i think on monday was a talk about the
data api consortium that tries to
standardize apis um and that yeah it's
easier to
to write code that works on multiple
libraries or multiple data frame
libraries and i think a behavior like
this will be much easier to
ensure
some standardization between different
data frame libraries
because yeah you you don't want or you
also you cannot try to imitate the
current behavior of pandas on this on
this topic
um
to be clear and to to [ __ ] it's a
proposal it's not something that already
exists in pandas
there are some resources here uh a blog
post a full
written out proposal with much more
detail and examples
there is a
github issue
if you want to get to those links uh
probably the easiest is to uh go to that
link and there you find a link to the
slides and then you can click on those
links instead of
trying to type it over um
and so feedback is very much welcome
both on the concept as later on if you
actually have a prototype so i'm there
is already
an initial prototype implementation
if you want to get like updated when
it's ready you can maybe follow the
github issue that's one way to get uh
updates and so yeah feedback is is very
much uh
welcome and so here's the link again and
uh thank you for listening
[Applause]
so let's move on to the q a session this
is the gentle reminder that now you can
vote if you haven't done it
and
the first question i have here
is also one that personally interests me
sounds great when do we get it
that's a good question um i can't
guarantee anything on that uh i hope
um so it's it's yeah we still need to
decide in the pandas community on like
yeah do we actually want it um do is it
feasible um how are we going to um
implement it like in in what kind of
um yeah transition period personally i
would like to see it
in the coming at least an option as an
optional or as
optionally with warnings um that we can
have people test it out this year
um in hopefully in the in the next
pandas release and then it's probably
based a bit on feedback if it if it goes
well i hope that we can have it in for
example pandas 2.0 which is planned for
um in the in later this year or next
year
but yeah that's very much
um
yeah
not guaranteed
okay
maybe as a follow-up i've seen several
questions asking if there's a general
majority of pandas developers supporting
this change or is it a early stage
proposal um it has it's something that
already has been
been discussed for many years
it's i think they're mostly um
many people and also like feedback that
i that we got from
yeah people teaching pandas is mostly
positive so i it's mostly a matter of
yeah having an implementation and then
testing that implementation and and
that's something that i'm trying to
to do at the moment but it's yeah it's
for me it's also a bit the side project
so it's
yeah going not always super fast
um
a lot of people seem to wonder
why not use in place equals true
why not use in place equals two um but
so i showed it uh i said it here um so
you one it's um you you can certainly
use it but
one argument is that it breaks
method chaining of course if you don't
use meta chaining then you don't care
about this
another argument is that it's currently
the in-place keyboard is currently
implemented in many places in pandas
but also in many places where it's
actually not
doing anything in place it's just
internally copying the data frame and
then
yeah replacing or replacing the copying
the the underlying data and replacing
inside the the python object the data
frame object just replacing the data
with the new data so it's it looks as it
is in place in the
data frame object but it's not actually
in place when it comes to
the data itself and so it's a that also
makes it a very inconsistent and
confusing keyword because people think
in many cases i can avoid memory
usage by putting that and often it
doesn't actually do that
um in some cases it can do that in
others not so it's that makes it an yeah
a not very um loved keyboard in the i
would say in the in the contributor uh
community
but um then a lot of people wonder
what would be arguments against this
change
they need to be downsized yeah um i
think there are there are
maybe i can show this
here
so one argument against the change is
that it's a breaking change and
yeah breaking changes it's backwards
incompatible always affects lots of
people because pandas is used is being
used by lots of people
and the clear breaking cases for example
this uh the one the example is on the
screen right now where there is a
chained assignment and one of those two
currently works
while under my proposal neither of them
would work um and and i think that's
by far the biggest
um
breaking change or the the the one
breaking change that impacts the most
people because that's something that
actually is being done right now so
that's a case where we will have need to
have very good warnings and maybe
keep those warnings after that it
actually has been changed so that people
are still getting aware that they're now
doing something that doesn't work
anymore
but um
so that's one argument um a second
argument can be that it deviates pandas
from
gets further away from numpy
um and how numpy works with copies and
views personally i think that many
users of panels are actually not
aware of those concepts in empire or at
least not exactly how this works so for
me it's
i would say that's not a i don't find
that a valid argument
another argument is also that i mean we
still need to see the implementation how
robust it is because
this this concept is it's implemented in
in pandas itself it's not like there are
some other languages where these those
concepts are very much like inside the
language itself in python that's not the
case so we we are trying to
emulate this in pandas using weak
crafts's
weak references and
and keeping track of that but yeah it's
there will certainly be some corner
cases or you will always be able to
manually circumvent that to still mutate
something where we can't make any
guarantees um but again that's more i
think corner cases for where people are
doing something that's
um yeah that where we can just say
that's
outside of the public api we don't
guarantee anything
i'm afraid unfortunately we have to come
to an end thank you so much for this
very insightful talk
[Music]
[Applause]